we are now going to talk about florida
what is going on in florida florida has
quickly become a coveted hellscape
we are seeing more cases basically in
all of the united states as i mentioned
earlier
in part it's because of the more
contagious delta variant uh and in part
it's because not nearly enough people
have been vaccinated
if you can believe it as of yesterday
afternoon
only 49.6 of the united states has been
fully vaccinated we are not
even at 50 percent yet even though
vaccines are
widely available safe and free
they are free so cases are spiking in
lots of places
but in many of these places
hospitalizations are not
spiking nearly as much or at all because
of the high vaccination rate so like
vermont would be one such example and
there are many that you can find
the u.s state of florida which has
become a cartoonish
trumpian farce led by republican
governor ron desantis
was hit not only uh has hit not only
a new single day pandemic long case
record
but it has also reached a record level
of covet hospitalization
right now today right now as we are
recording today's show
there is a record number of
hospitalization for covid in the state
of florida
what is ron desantis doing he is trying
to ban any kind of mask mandates
and uh get everybody in school now as
you can see here
florida is setting its own new
single day case record they did it on
july 31st
with almost twenty two thousand cases
depending on the day
florida is regularly registering between
twenty and thirty percent
of the entire country's new cases that's
in one
state the state of florida but if it
were
merely cases among vaccinated people for
whom it's mostly a cold
it wouldn't be that big of a deal but
florida's hospitals are completely
filling up
first of all check out the positivity
rates in florida
which are 18.1 percent for the state in
broward county
it's a 14 positivity rate miami-dade 12
percent
monroe county 16 positivity
if your positivity rate is above about
five
it means you're not testing nearly
enough and you're not capturing
nearly enough of the people who are sick
when when you have an 18
positivity rate it means there's tons of
people not getting tested
who have the virus and are spreading the
virus and then maybe most importantly
hospitalizations are at a record
the associated press reporting that
florida breaks covid19
hospitalization record with more than
ten thousand two hundred patients
the sunshine state had ten thousand two
hundred and seven people hospitalized
with confirmed coveted cases
according to data reported to the u.s
department of hhs
the previous record was from july 23 of
2020
more than half a year before
vaccinations were widespread so
understand that hospitalization today in
florida
is about 20 higher than before anybody
was vaccinated florida is now leading
the nation
in per capita hospitalization some
people saying well david sir
florida has so many people yes but
florida is also leading
per capita hospitalizations in the last
week florida
is averaging 1500 adult hospitalizations
a day
and listen to this 35 pediatric
hospitalizations every day 35
kids in florida are being put into the
hospital
with covid and then what about deaths
well because
part of florida is vaccinated we don't
expect the death rate to get as high but
deaths are also climbing in florida much
more than nationally
daily deaths in florida they were down
to 22 a day they're now up to 55 a day
more than doubled
and based on the recent case explosion
we would expect dramatically higher
death counts in florida
in the next 15 to 20 days meanwhile
governor ron desantis
is almost campaigning for the virus
bragging about we're not going to do
mask mandates we're not going to do
guidelines
we're never shutting anything down we're
opening everything do
everything send kids to school but no
masks in school
if you were trying to have the worst
numbers in the country you'd basically
be doing what ron desantis is doing in
florida
will it get him negative consequences or
will he end up as the republican
presidential nominee in 2024
that's the question and because we do
have a real problem in this country with
ignorance
i am not ready to say this will
definitely hurt ron desantis
it's it's possible that somehow
because of the republican electorate ron
desantis comes out of this
looking like a freedom-loving hero
rather than a coveted hellscape creating
lunatic um remains to be seen
we'll have more on the explosive
situation in florida
on our instagram you can find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
and find me on instagram at david.pakman
one of our sponsors is md primary care
the easier
and more affordable way to do primary
care and they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on
your doctor will be available to you by
text phone and video chat it's not some
random
doctor on call your steady md doctor
has a limited number of patients you get
the attention you deserve and they can
help you
with anything your primary care doc
normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
you'll get 50 off your first month when
you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video